منذ ايام تمكنت مديريه امن محافظه
القليوبيه في مصر من اعاده طفل يدعى احمد
الشامي بعد تغيب عن اسرته لمده اربعه ايام
الشاميه تم اختطفه على يد مجهول استدرجه
من احد محلات الالعاب الالكترونيه بجوار
منزله مرتكب الواقعه اوهم الطفل البالغ من
العمر سبع سنوات بانه سيفتح له حسابا على
لعبه ببجي واصطحبه بعيدا بعد استغاثه
الاسره وفحص كاميرات المراقبه بمحيط
المنطقه نجحت اجهزه الامن في تحديد هويه
الجان وضبطه قبل ان تعيد الطفل لاسرته
الحمد لله على سلامه ابنك وبالتالي سؤال
الابرز كيف حدث ذلك ايه اللي حصل ازاي مين
الراجل ده الراجل ده ما اعرفهوش هو جه
قدام البيت لعب مع الاطفال بتاعه الشارع
قدام بابجي وبعد كده خد الواد على اساس
اللي هو يعمل له ايميل ببجي
وصاحبه لحد الشارع وبعد كده ما بانش ثاني
بقى الكاميرات ايه اللي جابته تابعنا
الكمرات وزاره الداخليه تابعت الكاميرات
وجابته بعد اربعه ايام من قليوب محمد قديش
يعني ما بعرف بهذا الزمن اللي احنا فيه
هل تعتقد بانه في مسؤوليه نوعا ما على
الاهل بانهم على الاقل يتحدثوا مع اولادهم
يفهموا الاولاد انه مش المفروض تتحدثوا مع
اي شخص غريب واكيد مش المفروض انكم تذهبوا
مع اي شخص غريب حتى لو قال لكم راح اعطيكم
حلويات او اعمل لكم اي
حساب على لعبتكم المفضله اه انا كنت كل
يوم بقول له الكلام ده كنت كل يوم بقول له
ما تمشيش مع حد ما تاخدش حاجه من حد وبرده
الاهالي برده كان المفروض تعمل كده
ولكن على ما يبدو براءه الاطفال بتخليهم
انه يصدقوا اي شخص بيجي بقول لهم بدي اعمل
بدي اخذكم على مكان جميل او او اعطيكم
حلويات وممكن انهم يذهبوا معه هو المفروض
اي طفل ما يمشيش وراء اي حد واعمل ابني
مشي مش وراه على اساس اللي هو يجيب له
ايميل ببجي ومش ايميل ببجي وضحك عليه طبعا
وخدوه وقعد اربعه ايام
وجبناها من القليوب الحمد لله هو هو قال
ايه في اعترافاته قال ايه المتهم المتهم
طبعا
يعني معترف اللي هو خاطف الواد ومش بس انا
بطلب بطلب اللي هو ياخذ اعدام عشان ما
يعملهاش محدش يعملها ثاني
طيب
يعني لاحظت الحمد لله انه يعني ابنك بصحه
جيده جنبك هل تحدثت انت وياه الولد هل
اعطاك يعني قال اي قصص حول كيف وين وين
اخذوا كيف قضى هذول الايام هل كان يطعميه
مثلا ام لا هو طبعا يعني هو قاعد بيه
ليلتين في على محطه قليوب طبعا الواد كان
متبهدل برده من قله الاكل والكلام ده بس
الحمد لله رجع لي بالسلامه يعني